[Music]
what is up everyone and welcome to
simulation we are sitting down with dr.
Roman yon Polsky hello hello thanks for
coming out of the show thanks for having
me really yeah again we had Roman on
through Skype
earlier this year yes yes that was a
really important he's in Louisville and
at the University of Louisville and we
he is a 10 years as a associate
professor there well not all of them as
associated with 10 years yes the newest
is very important and then AI safety and
security research has been this very
important aspect of your life as well as
now civilizations life and so we got to
chat a bit about that over Skype but
this is really good in person to be able
to sit down together and dive into this
sure thanks for coming on again and you
were just you were just at Myrtle Beach
doing a keynote there and then it came
here won the foresight fellowship yep
for say Institute fellowship which is an
awesome great award to win thanked and
partake in their AI workshop behind
closed doors we don't know we don't know
what happened it's good to keep it
private
that's good much dangerous yeah China's
listening fake news fake news is
listening sad so yeah we'll go through a
couple of things that you actually spoke
about in the keynote some of the main
slides which which you and I are gonna
dive into I thing I thought were
actually very provoking maybe maybe
beforehand in the last couple of weeks
especially because it's moving so fast
what's been going on for you too much
travel so I basically go from place to
place telling people about what AI is
going to do for them and to them and the
specific conference was professionals
cyber security experts forensic experts
a lot
FBI but many of them have no idea what
the state of the art is and artificial
intelligence I spoke about for example
deep takes creation of forensic evidence
which is really similar to
realistic-looking representations yeah
let's do it
let's let's pull let's pull this up onto
the screen and and start start talking
about this because you mean it's the
first thing that you brought up and you
said that we have FBI cops CIA security
lots of people here wondering what the
state of the art is currently and how to
understand it you said - you said - you
said two distinct ways what's happening
for us and what's happening to us so
it's a dual use technology obviously
it's incredibly beneficial so much can
be done without a nation of labor
physical cognitive but the more capable
technology gets the more it can do it
independently and that's not always
beneficial for us so this specific set
of examples the part in the bottom is
from the militia say I report came out I
think couple months ago a large
conglomerate of different universities
nonprofits put together a report on what
we can expect from kind of dangerous AI
produced by hackers malevolent actors
and one of the examples talked about
advance advances we make in creating
fake data both to fool humans and to
fool computers you see how quickly
something like synthetic human images
changes four years ago we have this
black and white low resolution now I
can't even tell if it's real image again
either and this is 2017 it's been a year
so take it to the next level now we do
full-blown deep fake videos yes you can
get anyone to appear like they saying
anything you want yes
political candidate friends family you
name it so that's also dual use right
you can frame someone or you can give
someone a way out I didn't do it it's
fake news now I have good justification
to claim it's not real
so this so the repercussions of this
being indistinguishable from reality are
not only for blackmailing people but
also for saying fake news deniability if
i can take a simple iphone app i think
that is like a fake app or something and
I can make my friends and family to
appear to say certain things and
everyone knows it's trivial to do next
time a video of a president or someone
comes out saying crazy things
is it real it depends on the president
but still it's bringing into doubt the
whole concept of forensic evidence what
we use in the judicial system
statistical analysis right now probably
will allow an expert to tell if it's
generate it or not but very quickly this
goes away the moment I understand what
signature you're looking for I can work
and removing it from my face that's the
way it's generated right you have
competing neural networks one faking
data one looking for fakes they meet in
the middle so it's a 50/50 chance it's
real give us a very quick cliff notes
understanding of how we take analysis of
a human face and we turn a digital
version that looks identical to the
actual meat all right so generative
adversarial networks work by studying
data some sort of training data set and
from that learn to create imitations
they are presented to another network
whose job it is to tell fake data from
real data think of like currency forgery
right somebody's faking dollars
somebody's an expert in telling fake
dollars from real dollars and they
compete and one gets better the other
catches up and so eventually they meet
in the middle where the good guy you
don't never can no longer tell if data
is fakery with better than flip of a
coin probability so that's where we're
at right now basically we're starting to
look as real as reality and there are a
few other cool examples a lot of his
work is from ian Goodfellows group
they're generating
attacks not just an artificial neural
networks but on human neural networks so
the image here the cab dog duality and
the left you have the cat image the
picture of a cat on the right you have
an image modified just slightly a few
pixels to where most humans think it's a
picture of a dog now similar attack but
now on artificial neural networks you
have two images which kind of look the
same to a human face yeah but one on the
left is identified as a male with almost
100% accuracy by neural networks the one
on the right the exact opposite
guaranteed female holy cow so basically
what we usually perceive as optical
illusions is now kind of automatically
produced and can be used to fool us in
many domains and so this is that stat
5050 point 5050 cat a couple pixels
well 5050 is a way to generate the
adversarial inputs whereas this is waste
robotics all difference can get you a
whole different result of binary right
different results and we're very good at
doing it for computers a single pixel a
couple pixels can change something
obviously recognizable to a human to a
completely different label for a
computer but now we're starting to be
better at doing it against humans so
it's possible that in the future you'll
be shown advertisements were on a
surface it looks like a but subliminally
you're getting B over way so it's kind
of deceptive deep fakes Wow
that is gonna be I mean we're really at
that at that right here right now in the
political sphere watching a video of
somebody and not knowing if it's real or
not exactly that's crazy yeah Wow
I would love to ask you like what we do
- how does civilization move forward
with something like that well the nature
of evidence will change we can no longer
rely just on a picture or even a video
you need much stronger evidence at least
in serious cases picture and video which
used to be the most reliable right is
now unreliable starting to be it's still
not as full-fledged but what would be
more reliable now than video and images
for now things like DNA evidence would
probably be pretty good but we're
starting to create synthetic DNA
sequences so that's not gonna be there
for long testimony of witnesses never
been reliable to begin with if you have
multiple witnesses it improves your
chances but still so it's an open area
of research even DNA is now no-go
oh we're not now not now we're still
using it it's still reliable but the
technology is becoming available to
where we can synthesize short strands of
DNA eventually complete genomes right
and then what do we use for evidence
well we're starting to have a lot more
surveillance right we have cameras
everywhere we have if they know where
you are all the time based on yes
immediately record the data to the
blockchain timestamp it yeah it's less
likely to be fake because it's part of a
historical record so technology is
always kind of again we see this
catching up there's there's no escaping
with surveillance is there really
you can do better with privacy online if
you encrypt your activities if you use
ways to connect anonymously but probably
not if someone really wants to find out
what you're doing well also the areas of
the world where like the Sentinelese
people off in the Indian Ocean have yet
to be contacted by modern-day
civilization I know nothing about them
probably that's why I will absolutely
tell you about them and then also send
you some materials but every time that
they've attempted to be contacted by the
outside world it's been violence has
been Spears and so there's and there's
we can't approach them because of that
unless we harm and we can't so I'm
curious then there's there's still how
many of these little pockets of no
surveillance and how long will they be
pockets of no surveillance will have any
specific dates but it seems it's the
more prominent you are the less privacy
you have if you are yeah one of those
people you mentioned as some few people
want to really follow you daily so it's
less of a problem for them I don't think
I've ever actually fully realized that
it's the complete end of privacy and
it's the command it's the complete serve
the transition to a surveillance state
but in hopefully in benevolent ways that
hopefully ensure with technologies like
blockchain with technologies like
benevolent leadership hopefully so if
you think about it what is privacy you
only need it because you're scared of
punishment for doing things you're doing
which you shouldn't be doing or maybe
someone in the future would think you
shouldn't be doing if you truly lived in
a free society without any punishment
for your activities you won't care about
your privacy right whatever you did you
did nobody cares there is no
losing employment losing friends going
to prison so the more privacy you need
the more it indicates that you're not
truly living in a free society so maybe
the notion of privacy will change if you
look at social media it used to be
really weird to know what you had for
lunch now kids taking pictures of their
burgers or whatever everything's online
I know where you are what you eating and
that's not considered normal yeah yeah
so privacy evolves with technology ok
that was a crazy intro into our
conversation Wow this is what you do
every [ __ ] day
you talk to people about this it's fun
work ok so so okay now I want to maybe
ask a question about this because a lot
of us have seen videos of Boston
Dynamics and the Boston Dynamics is
doing a fairly good job at making robots
that are able to move even better than
humans can move and do tasks even better
than humans can do tasks in conditions
that they don't have to sleep they don't
have emotions they don't have to eat
they don't have to poop etc just like
the robots they need to recharge the
battery so when you mount a gun onto one
of these we're talking some serious [ __ ]
yes but it's not just military robots
you can put a gun on a drone just a
commercial drone or even an upstander
drone available to hobbies you can put
it in a self-driving car lots of ways
you can combine existing beneficial
technologies in the dangerous way
oh my god Wow so how do we ensure that
we don't have weapons on drones and
weapons and autonomous cars weapons on
these foot robot dogs I'm not sure we
can yeah we're not the answer your
question we're not more and more it
becomes possible for any person to
produce this technology right with a 3d
printer you can print guns so making
guns illegal is not gonna help you can't
make every drone illegal it's useful
commercial technology it's useful for
hobbyists so you can just outlaw those
things so really you have to learn to
live with them how the [ __ ] do we learn
to live with them anyone having access
to 3d printed guns and anyone being able
to put 3d printed guns on top of AI the
house computer vision and scanning the
environment and looking at your [ __ ]
face all the time like this is this is
more swearing than I'm used to for a
typical show reported right so this is
one of the biggest concerns I have is
that the cost of using this technology
to performing an attack becomes lower
and lower it used to be that only a
government agency or large corporation
had the resources but every day it
becomes cheaper and cheaper where anyone
can be a bad actor we see it with AI we
see it with synthetic biology we seaton
many of those exponential areas right to
become Manoa of malevolent
right the cost of entering that space is
almost nothing a drone can be purchased
for just over a hundred dollars put a
flamethrower and it put a spy cam around
lots of options is there a way to figure
out how to work across the world to
prevent man malevolent use of this
technology I don't see what so we just
had a workshop on exactly that how to
get governments and corporations to talk
to figure out ways to collaborate on
developing safer AI but those are just
conversations there is nothing specific
in place most countries are not subject
to some agreements so if we can get
couple players to agree maybe us in
China that's good but there is not a
universal standard for what technology
to permit or not permit and it's again
because of decreasing costs not
necessarily the case that if big players
agree someone else will not do it
anyways
okay so if even at best that we ask
people to bring on ethicists and
philosophers into the conversations
there will still be people that I took
want to use them for harmful absolutely
the same people who develop let's say
computer viruses right now just
malevolent purposes whatever it's to
monetize things to cause damage to
become famous crazy people religious
cult suicide or whatever other enough
crazy people should see outside of your
studio yeah yeah did the techies and
homeless yeah it's crazy okay how about
how about is that then the solution to
but malevolent players is to have enough
superiority with the benevolent players
to take out the malevolent tech when it
starts it's something to try but there
is only so much room at the top right if
we're getting to AI at human level or
beyond there is not that much you can
have in terms of superiority if everyone
gets to let's say human level
so we've had Swami Anand on the shown he
taught us that meditation was the key to
unlock your infinite human potential and
so is it possible that tuning in word
and finding the divinity within yourself
and the divinity within your fellow
brothers and sisters on the planet that
that may actually not that we won't have
any mole of malevolent players not sure
how that guy is you mentioned and what
he accomplished his unlocking of
potential but I suspect it's only gonna
make your death less painless a
wonderful answer school this young man
Roman and his utopian vision for the
future let it go there's always gonna be
good and dad's the malevolent benevolent
things it's it's just gonna stay both of
them are gonna step up their game Alan
let it go with your utopian world where
everybody's dancing around the Maypole
and loving each other they sex orgy
Roman do you think that we can't get to
a point where we work all when we were
we all figure out how to work together
all the failed so far and then we might
do better in the future we can do worse
but so far it's all been about competing
and fighting right this has been very
realistic yeah that's what we want yeah
how do you know that it's not
collectively what we want that's what we
signed up for there is no other way
that's the only way to improve and get
better the only way to improve and get
better is through having a competing
source of information and data and power
and or just a low standard to compare
yourself to just the good the bad and
the ugly take it take a pic
end of the middle class they say pick a
side pick a side it's the end of the
middle class especially with the
proliferation of all the exponential
technologies that's one of the things
that we've been saying on the show
sometimes I don't know what that means
so pick a side it's the end of the
middle class so pick a side either
wealthy or ultra wealthy or poor I'll go
that way thanks for giving me options we
talked about the end of the middle class
and then picking sides and there being a
bifurcation in socioeconomic status what
do you think about that extreme wealth
could be very dangerous
it's possibly is cause of existential
risk as well we see it with some people
I think Jeff Bezos is what 130 billion
but think about AI running corporations
it's now today legally possible to put
algorithms in charge of corporations
where they can generate profit they can
reinvest profits you can start new
corporations so it's very likely that at
some point machines will have greatest
wealth and you can use money to
manipulate law to bypass laws so it's
dangerous for that reason okay so we had
we had Saudi Arabia that gave Sophia
legal citizenship so this is just a
little baby step there's
the step of being able to take the mass
amount of wealth that you have and then
have the algorithms produced you other
companies that are able to make you even
more wealth and have that cycle occur is
a cycle of radical wealth inequality so
dad this is very very very realistic and
very important to talk about
I'm de su so just just one more time to
just to check in with you one more time
here because of our history of of war
that there will continue being a war
right the reason we fight might change
we may no longer fight for same
resources but might fight for different
resources or decisions something like
should we build more capable intelligent
machines has been projected to be cause
of a third world war right Hugo de garis
in his book artilect war talks about
that as the fundamental divide between
people who want to preserve kind of
conservatives I guess preserve humanity
as it is versus progressives people who
want to move to the next level of
intelligence and give up what we have
for greater good of university I guess
it almost it almost sometimes it makes
me feel like that there is very
difficult future ahead of us and I hope
the species doesn't go extinct
Bernard Gunther said that he has no hope
in the future he doesn't like the future
do you like the future so far it looks
good for me
me too I'm stoked I'm gonna be a
criminal I was one of the bad guys yeah
I think I I think I'm excited for the
future but I hope that we can figure out
how to how to work together on these
these challenges understanding what the
problems are is still better than just
being ignorant and putting your head in
the sand and ignoring what's coming if
all of us realized what's happening
there is a much better chance we would
not make the same mistakes so it's good
to educate people politicians
policymakers scientists yeah about an
even average citizens everyone everyone
yeah yeah stupid policy and through that
education than more conversation and
then it weren't and then our hint that
our heads are not in the sand so a
little bit of a happy do have one
positive side yeah so AI is amazing in
that it can deliver so much for us it
can give us a lot of economic wealth
with free labor physical cognitive comes
trillions of dollars worth of product
services it can help us with science
the gamma super scientists think of
someone cross-disciplinary but PhDs in
every area who read every book knows
every research paper they can do so much
new science synthetic work so it can
help us develop unified theories of
science cure diseases cancer whatever
so there are tremendous benefit that's
why you can't just say we're gonna give
up the technology it's not feasible yeah
even if you forget financial incentives
there is just so much I mean how do you
tell someone who's dying from incurable
diseases we're not gonna help you it's
insane
the eradication of suffering that's what
I can rely for extension all sorts of
things were in need of help from someone
smarter than us to deliver yeah parsing
through all the millions of pieces of
data way faster and we can more
accurately just managing our world for
us it's becoming so complex we can no
longer keep up software is running
almost everything for us at this point
and it's not even that intelligent yeah
okay so other benevolent fields for AI
to permeate into so okay the social
fabric has become very complex and
artificial intelligence can help us
manage that social fabric between each
other between countries make things a
little bit smoother or less stressful
increase our lifespan decrease suffering
anything we're having smart assistant
would be useful would benefit from
having those machines hey there's a
little bit of utopia up there doesn't it
look kind of nice you got some flying
cars you got a couple Burj Khalifa
towers and yeah but you know most of the
unknown unknowns there are good things
we can't even think about which would be
delivered right we're not smart enough
to envision them yeah yeah you don't
know what's going on in those buildings
either you know may look nice on the
outside they probably having baby soup
or something you know crazy future
people well so the that chart the
unknown unknowns is kind of like what we
don't know about the universe that we
live in right now right so there could
be things pleasures we never experienced
before experiences in general qualia we
never considered it possible which could
be delivered
do you have any hypothesis into those no
if I did they wouldn't be unknown
unknowns but you kind of did have a
hypothesis which was that there there
are pleasures that we haven't sensed
haven't felt so I guess I'd be more of
known unknowns or unknown knowns we
aren't aware classification but again
yeah just weakened by definition kind of
see what a more capable agent would be
able to do
okay well benevolent enough of a more
capable agent could figure out how to
wire together the fabric to prevent
suffering and violence and so that's the
hope right everyone working on air
safety hopes that we can get to the
point where we have very capable and
safe and manageable system well aligned
with human desires values and capable of
growing with us in the future that is
the hope can we can we stay on the hope
that big hope that big hope is a nice
hope if it makes me feel a little better
okay I'm on it I'm working so that so
the big hope is aligned with the goals
of humanity what when we live
harmoniously together with the
artificial intelligence that we build to
progress civilization all right so it's
interested in doing things which we like
and beneficial to us and preserve us in
some good way and there are
organizations that are doing that right
now quite a few okay oh yeah well openly
I has a safety team they not fully
working in it not you and then foresight
Institute our site that is of course
machine intelligence Research Institute
machine intelligence Research Institute
here in Berkeley and Berkeley mm-hmm it
is future of life Institute future of
humanity Institute yeah enough very
creative with names but yeah we would be
honored to have some of them also on
so so if you wanna interesting people so
long stop swearing stop swearing so much
and maybe they might come on these are
intelligent people they're dealing with
our official intelligence act like a man
yeah I was I was swearing quite a bit at
the beginning that's true that's true
that's true
I do enjoy swearing and some
psychological tests have shown that
people that swear more more honest and
more intelligent that's what I always
tell my kids yeah well well because I
you can you can use it to kind of add a
little bit of a an extra kick a little
more emphasis to what you're saying
because it's that much more emphasis is
needed on the severity of what is being
said maybe but if you kick everything
just the default the plastic elsewhere I
guess your food is too spicy okay all
right let's the positive impacts
hopefully we talked about some of this
already so the point is just it's a
follow up slide it's a dual use
technology for every positive it is a
negative for three Libra you get
technological unemployment what do you
do with all the people who lose their
jobs yeah and not all of them can just
learn some of the new harder jobs you
can take minors in Kentucky and make
them into data miners people try and I
and I've argued about this with Jordan
Peterson a couple months ago is it
possible that it might not happen in six
months but could it happen in six years
that the same person will learn no
plasticity over six threats so more and
more jobs have a minimum intelligence
requirement it used to be that anyone
could do any job if I had IQ of 80 now
certain jobs require you to have a IQ of
let's say 130 if you don't you can't do
the job it just is beyond you not
everyone could be a neurosurgeon if we
could train everyone to do that I'd be
just not the reality so a lot of jobs
which will be automated at first a kind
of low level high repetition easy to do
low IQ jobs so to expect the same people
to all become AI developers it's just
not realistic creative talent seems like
there could be some potential could be
some potential in the hybrid the
transitionary stage of the next couple
of decades right so there could be
period where we create a lot of new jobs
and people shift but long term every job
is going to be automated your job might
rapid doesn't matter yeah mushrooms will
be better than us there could still be
some niche market for human meat
products because people find it cute or
something but there is no commercial
level need for that is what is then the
future of work so for most people
they're happy not to have to work they
do it for money they don't enjoy what
they do however people may be you may be
me we actually like what we're doing I'm
not doing it for money so for me having
guaranteed income and then doing what I
want would not be a problem I'd still
continue learning creating nothing
changes for people who have horrible
jobs they punch a card or do something
boring repetitive they'll be happy not
to have to work so for many people that
would be a feature now a lot of people
identify themselves with their careers
and if that's gone they kind of lose
their identity what's the purpose of
your life right they've been selling
cars their whole life they were proud of
how good they are as a sales person and
just kind of taking pride in that if
that's gone they need to find new
meaning in life I don't know if it's
creating art or writing poetry or
playing sports but they need something
else to be there
my service 40-hour gap in their day
their week in in the long term with the
decrease in the amount of work that
there will be and eventually to the
point where they're everything that is
being done is being done better by AI
then what even what even happens if even
the creative work is better done by AI
so economy has to adapt to that somehow
if you can produce more wealth with no
human labor required how do you
redistribute that right you don't have a
standard paycheck money kinda becomes
less meaningful so you need to find a
way to maybe somehow tax production of
machines and they distribute that to
humans especially humans who lost their
jobs to that automation so people talk
about unconditional basic income basic
assets things of that nature that could
be a good solution okay
yeah big base ok basic income takes a
front seat let's say as very wealthy
people accrue more wealth and automate
jobs of people that have less wealth
University basic income takes the the
front seat there and provides them with
their basic necessities and then having
things when they're when me having
something doesn't preclude you or anyone
else from having something that you big
need access to these items also makes it
so that there is not a
that-that-that's stress that we
currently have on humanity of having
exclusive access to items based on
wealth might not might not no longer
occur if it's if anyone can have access
to a yacht or whatever it is certain
things will still be rare there is only
so much waterfront property so rare art
but most things food clothes can be
produced so much infinitely yeah
waterfront property in between the to do
tropics in between two lines of Tropic
that cancer Capricorn that it's probably
enough waterfront property in there for
everybody I'm sure eventually you run
out of Earth to support everyone do you
think that the population is stabilizing
the replacement fertility rate people
were in developed countries so I think
life extension will do a lot for how we
see need to reproduce if we live forever
would be less likely to have children
period children a kind of a way to
prolong your life to replace yourself
yeah
whereas if I'm not going anywhere I have
less pressure to have kids at 20 yeah
okay so if children being born in 2018
are almost guaranteed to be living in
what a hundred years pretty much there
is a point of kind of escape velocity
where you live long enough to live
forever for every year you live the
medicine becomes so advanced that you
gain more than you lose
yes and so at that every the whole
paradigm of existence changes I don't
need to procreate I can I can live I can
spend more time traveling in your 20s or
your 30s or building a couple different
businesses throughout time or doing
whatever you want everything changes
everything changes investment strategy
will change marriage certainly
restraining till death do us part is no
longer escape clause yeah yeah yeah
exactly
Wow
yeah you can have multiple marriages as
a normality be a contract based
remarried for next 50 years and then we
have an option to renew but we don't
have to have an option to renew yeah
actually a we've we've had a couple
people that have taught us about that
there is something very interesting
about the two people going into a
marriage with a more logical take on
what is actually going on between them
to the point where they are literally
saying okay like every every month we
have a meeting to talk about how our
marriage is going and then after a year
then we can choose how many times we
want to meet per month and they have it
all written out in logic in their
agreement it seems like a pretty
rational I suspect they would be less
likely to get divorced yeah
I suspect that too yeah okay so all
right this is this is a good way that
you have explained AI safety and
security so it's kind of my interest
slide so what is the area of research
I'm working on I combine cybersecurity
efforts to create safe secure machines
and artificial intelligence efforts to
create capable machines into one science
engineering of developing machines which
are not just beneficial but safe and
secure safe meaning safe for humanity to
use insecure meaning they cannot be
hacked ooh yeah
jeopardy is their performance safe to
use and secure so that they can't be
hacked in jeopardized and then you you
also said that both the machines are are
they're capable and they're also what
was the other one they safe relief
auntie they're our capability they don't
have side effects which are damaging to
humanity they secure against external
threats
yeah aimed at creating safe and secure
machines it's a good way to put her on
it yeah very laconic you know not sure
the name seems to take off I started
this a while ago at the time there were
so many different labels we talked about
machine ethics we talked about friendly
AI but now it seems like most people
went with us so I'm very happy I think
it makes a lot of sense and I think it
rings with people like you said yeah and
we can learn so much we can learn from
the field of security it's been around
for a long time so every security they
have developed tools for testing for
evaluating systems for and explaining
what is secure so that's useful to us
so Hawking Musk Obama Gates Wozniak
every one of them has an opinion about
the importance of this conversation
right so at the time it was kind of
fringe topic talking about
superintelligence dangerous of a guy so
I wanted to make a point that it's
becoming more and more mainstream to
hear President of the United States
speak about super intelligence that was
incredible at the time yeah now it's
kinda more establish their conferences
journals books coming out so it's less
amazing but still good to have people
who are well recognized talk about it
which brings more respect to feel more
funding certainly from you learn mass
consumer
what is the most important thing that
you've heard a global leaders say about
it
well I heard both kind of supportive
statements such as those that's why I
picked them that would be example of
support but also very dismissive there
are AI risk skeptics I don't want to say
deniers but we can certainly apply that
label to existing a Iife
they don't think currently ice can be
the interest in its denialism figure
skeptical about future AI
superintelligence being dangerous it's
reasonable you can be skeptical we don't
know how technology is going to be I
think it's more likely that there is
something to worry about but there are
people who dismiss it as insane to worry
about them that would be examples of
that I don't want to go into specific
names and yeah and then what's the
importance of getting women and people
of color on here Asian black women
Mexican Latino you know what the
solution right now we see to this
problem is value alignment getting
machines to do what we value what we
care about but who is we it's not just
me and you it's the whole planet right
so we need to get values from everyone
to make it a complete picture yeah the
the values of whatever 300 million
people in the u.s. is so much different
that's only whatever 5% of the of the
population oh we didn't have a noise we
didn't have the buzzer
don't you know how to I have no idea
what I'm doing now not at all so we're
at our 15 minute timer so taking a
sample of the values of other
demographics in the world as we produce
they are the eyes that harmoniously live
next to us is crucial right there is
probably majority of people who are not
represented in this slide maybe so it's
important to make sure they are
incorporated and they feel like
technology we develop works for them so
we have so many examples where datasets
with Trena and don't have any faces of
specific types so the system wouldn't
recognize them wouldn't allow them
access to the resource wouldn't allow
them to interact with an app and that's
unacceptable if your company selling a
product how can you dismiss your
customers like that more of the voices
across different populations of people
will be an important aspect of the
conversation so your book is in the
middle artificial superintelligence a
Fewster futuristic approach and then
your second book and we'll have the
links in the bio for everyone
second book artificial intelligence
safety and security it's coming out in
August thesis of the upcoming book so
the first book was by me it's an outer
book so it was all about my research
this is an edited book the goal was to
get all the top AI safety researchers to
contribute what they think is good
solutions whatever outstanding problems
so it's a large book I think it's close
to 500 pages
well it's 27 chapters from pretty much
every
name in the field and some up-and-coming
young researchers I think it's very
exciting to get such diversity some are
highly technical choppers very useful as
a textbook for engineering courses hours
essays about future of humanity opinion
pieces so you can skip around find
what's suitable for your interests for
your course this is great as a textbook
great as a just casual read about half
of a book is seminal papers by top
scholars which have been previously
published somewhere but never kind of
combined into a single volume whereas
the second half is all novel papers
novel solutions can you give us an
insight into some of the novel solutions
that we're gonna learn about you have to
buy the book I have to buy the book
what's a general what's a general
principle that people are that the
community is kind of well I think that's
a strength of a book it's so cognitively
diverse there is not a single thing
everyone's trying they're completely
unrelated solutions and related
chaplains live in unrelated problems
some people look at deep fakes generated
images some people look at what you
brought up with bias issues how do we
address discrimination by algorithms
ours are only interested in aligning
super intelligent systems complete
diversity so it's a spectrum from
problems we have today with existing
eyes to future problems with super
intelligent systems and I think we're
doing a good job kind of covering
everything in between some some problems
I didn't think about before reading the
chapters awesome that is great work on
kind of manipulation of human beliefs
knowledge by ice through media through
stories through shared parts they're
gonna that but even so much more
interactive interaction you have friends
some social media you interact with them
if hundreds of them are BOTS designed to
influence your opinion to make you feel
certain way to shift your vote how does
that impact democracy how does that
impact
everything we do a society because so
much of what you do is based on how many
likes you got what your friends liked
and if that's manipulated do you feel
comfortable making a statement which
everyone hates and those existing
problems would exist in technology this
is not even something we have to wait
for I was I was recently learning that
Japan gained access to smart phone
technology earlier than the United
States did and the kind of the
sociological psychological analysis of
the way that people in Japan are in
interacting with one another now is a
little bit more reclusive and that they
believe that part of that has to do with
what was the social medias effect has
taken and I wonder if the West is about
to experience something like that as
well because a lot of people have social
anxiety and I think it's really
important to practice so that you don't
have social anxiety but some people
don't need to practice because they can
just do all of their work in a non
social setting and then do they really
need to practice why
well isn't Japan dying out they stopped
having relationships stopped reproducing
so yeah I think there is a reason to
learn those skills yeah yeah it's an
experiment we're running in ourselves
and our children will give them those
new devices the moment they are born one
year olds have iPads and we have no idea
what its gonna do to their development
yeah
yeah we we've we've passed sometime
around younger kids around the age of 10
even younger and a little older and
there's some very strange social
behavior that's already occurring
where there's a reliance on the device
and there's not a reliance on the
communication between the the people and
that is that's strange
to say the least is just strange it's
different and we don't know where that's
going and I'm glad that your book covers
everything from today to the future and
transdisciplinary problems in the field
along the way yeah there'll be a good
book to buy put in the studio and have
people take a look at have us read and
take a look at and then do another show
in the fall maybe we'll have enough
budget to fly you out here for once
we'll get there sounds like a plan
no this is this is interesting for so
many reasons because obviously the
show's called simulation and simulation
theory is very fascinating for us for
many reasons probably most importantly
that if you just take all the variables
of this rock orbiting this star and then
you just tweak the variables slightly
differently for other rocks orbiting
stars and just watch how they evolve
what actually occurs on those rocks
orbiting stars and so when we gain
enough computing power to be able to run
these simulations ourselves and and see
exactly how life evolves I think it'll
give us a better understanding into this
example of do you actually know that you
are real do you know that other people
are real that's the Braeden of that and
then the other one is the neural lace
itself has take selfie with you on a
little
now that was at the conference in
California right yeah where's what's
that city you got a Silla Mar Asilomar
yeah they still do that every year every
two years and not necessarily same place
every two years and what's the
conference called again the beneficial
yeah been officially I in is what are
your thoughts about the getting to the
point of of being able to run
simulations solipsism just in general so
this specifically is proposed as ways to
compete with machines right we have to
enhance ourselves become smarter faster
so we can keep up what do I think about
becoming an upload it seems like it has
certain benefits you don't have to get
food in the traditional way you can have
a good backup of yourself but there
seems to be possibility that it would
not perfectly capture your experiences
your qualia I'm not sure about that it
seems like it's an open the senses the
senses right you did this like for
example with a digital consciousness
you'll have a Bureau of a backup of
yourself you'll be able to move more
freely we won't have to eat won't have
to sleep these types of things but you
may miss some other senses I'm just not
fully sure it's gonna be me it will be
you yeah yeah yeah you know what yeah
sense of how do you take this I like
having it window I care of that I have
it win it's not me right it's just a
copy but it's the difference between me
and a copy
so that would be 86 billion neurons
connected to a computer that would then
send the the way that the neural
architecture is synchronizing and firing
to the cloud and let it somehow be able
to live on the cloud then and do its
thing as a digital form of you that was
still working in technology but the idea
is to be able to simulate all the
neurons of the connections everything
and I guess at least part of the
environment otherwise where would you
exist right so it's even more
computationally intensive do you do you
do you think that you that do you think
of solipsism much that you're the only
one that's real and that other people
you can't necessarily know if are real
or not so I think about it
I don't know how to experimentally test
this you know it seems like one possible
solution to the issue of value alignment
is to give everyone an individual
universe where you get exactly what you
want and I get what I want in my
universe so that would explain this yeah
so if we already in a simulation and
it's run by super intelligent but
beneficial system then perhaps everyone
is getting a unique one yeah customized
with all the non playing characters yeah
as I was asking you that question
it felt really interesting because I was
thinking from your perspective about
solipsistic then if you're actually
thinking about salsas and giving this
answer and I am myself then maybe we are
both real because of that no nice you're
not real
the simulation is falling apart I'm
falling apart you brought it up and it
started collapsing around unethical
research we have
I'll both we're already throwing in
we're already doing genetic engineering
we're already doing lots of testing
let's what give us a quick understanding
of I want to hear quick on the research
review boards because that has to do
with what you helped push forward right
so in medical experiments specifically
it's very common for universities at
least for corporations to have some sort
of review board you have a proposal to
do experiments well look at it we'll go
okay whatever
we'll sacrifice this animal but we'll
get this result so it's a legitimate
thing to do this is like brutal for no
reason and you're just torturing animals
so we're going to reject this proposal
at the time it seemed crazy to require
any type of approval to write software
but if there is really a possibility
that what you create will have impact
and everyone and maybe a negative one it
seems very reasonable to have someone
look over and go this is not a good idea
you have no safety plan in place yet
it's very likely to succeed let's not do
that so since we published on that i
think google deepmind had a contract
with google during acquisition that
they're gonna establish a safety board
and i think three or four other
companies might now have it as well a
safety board safety board for safety
party they don't publicize who's on it
or how much power they have yeah it
could be just an advisory board not
necessarily board with power to retract
certain research but still it's at least
good to know that they care enough to
set it up yeah and then in the in the
conclusion failures will grow in
frequencies and severity proportionate
to a ice capability right so I collect
examples of how a ice fail and I started
with kind of birth of a field and
they're hilarious on your that go follow
Roman on Facebook and Twitter please but
it seems like obviously because we have
more a eyes now
there is more opportunities for them to
fail and to have more impact because
they do so much more and this will
continue the severity of the failure
right so as the systems control more and
more we'll see more and more or less
examples and the simple rule you can
kind of extract abstract away from all
those failures whatever it is we
designed the system to do it will
eventually fail to do it and you can
apply it to future things if you know
what the eye is going to be in the
future yeah it's gonna fail at that if
it's designed to drive around safely
it's gonna kill someone okay homes kind
of trivial now but we can project to the
future and see what's happening so it's
at least useful for product
manufacturers to kind of go very
releasing this new product what can
possibly go wrong that's a that's a
pretty good conclusion as the current
frequency and severity of the issues
that we're facing is kind of like haha
and then like eventually it's a serious
serious no we talked about things I know
Microsoft chat BOTS started swearing so
kind of like you know not a big deal
right we can move on but if we're
talking about military weaponized a nice
going hacked or you know yeah so Roman
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world you asked me last
time what was your answer I don't
remember I said something so profound it
was beautiful even better than let's see
if it matches yeah yeah yeah I guess it
changes everything it does change yeah
yeah this time I feel like consciousness
just qualia experiencing the world is so
amazing all of it from pain to pleasure
yeah the whole spectrum what's your
favorite favorite feeling of being alive
favorite feeling of being most alive
feeling what what is that for you
hmmm I think being with nature is kind
of fulfilling you know truly
experiencing this planet this simulation
to its finest yes the situation to its
finest and because I know you've you
have answered the cosmos and the alone
question
let's ask you another question
let's ask you about time what is your
definition of time so I trust physicists
with what they claim the difference
between movements you need things to
exist in the physical world to create
time don't have any weird definitions
for us but can you give us a percentage
of what you think is gonna be happening
in the next like couple decades in terms
of malevolent or benevolent future with
a I I'm not gonna give you such
percentages just because I don't know
when any guess would be meaningless but
I can tell you that as of today no one
in the world has a working safety
mechanism which would scale to any level
AI and no one even has a prototype as in
no one has any idea how to control
intelligent intelligent systems to at
large scales to prevent malevolent use
yeah to ensure whatever use the ones on
them we just don't know how to do it and
you need like thousands of very
sophisticated programmers and designers
architects artists we have no idea we
kind of doing this patchwork okay this
is a problem let's see if we can fix
this but there yeah like a fractal of
those where every time we zoom in to see
what the problem is we discover as many
new problems and it continues there is
never a growing we solve this we no
longer have to worry about this part and
the safety mechanisms themselves can
have mistakes on them
can cause problems right so by adding
the safety mechanism we see it a lot
with software a page to fix a previous
exploit creates a new exploit so you
have a lot of job security the way you
explained it fractal ink is crazy that
that's how many new things arise as you
figure out how to solve things with AI
that can be with the social fabric in a
harmonious way can we figure that out
where are we even at thank you for
bringing this up into the light of our
world into the light of more people's
worlds my pleasure
thanks for coming out of the Shogun well
greatly appreciate it and I hope that
what we talked about today was
inspirational for everyone that tuned in
if so definitely give us a subscribe
definitely give us a comment below let
us know your thoughts share the video
with other people have more
conversations about AI safety and
security and as we always say don't just
consume but go and create with this
content going write about it go and make
videos about it I know Ron is attempting
to play good music so we'll turn it up
and on the way out go create make stuff
with this go create and especially
create in the field of AI safety and
security let's get more conversation
going about this join us on patreon we
need to continue sustaining the studio
space and growing bringing out Roman
when he releases his book in Layton
later in August and thank you everyone
for tuning in thanks Roman greatly
appreciate it thank you Ron Alfredo our
team much love thank you and we'll see
you guys soon peace